basically tony hawk did a skateboard
with blood mm-hmm
and uh
they like took some of his blood and
they put it into these limited edition
skateboards or whatever it was weird um
with the paint right yeah i guess that
makes sense but like and then
everybody's making this big comparison
to um
well not sex night why when little knots
did it it's [ __ ] up and when tony hawk
did it it's not [ __ ] up he made that
whole post who did little nazis little
nazak's really leaning you guys be
honest like it wasn't the blood it was
just something else what was it yeah i
mean they do hate you because you're gay
yeah but the excuse you gave them wasn't
the blood it was the devil yeah you gave
like little nazix gave them the out by
talking about the devil and devil
worship and all this other stuff and i
don't think it was the blood that was in
these sneakers that he was selling it
was the devil that was these sneakers
they were saying if you're like
plus blood but the blood means nothing
if he was like hey he's still a devil
sneaker and then all these christians
that saw their kids listening to old
town road and now they're like oh [ __ ]
that guy is not only gay but he's also
saying devil worship i'm going to twerk
on the devil and
boom exactly so i i think that he's
this is this is kind of unfair and he he
knows it but you got to keep marketing
[ __ ] and drumming yeah entertainment but
it's not about blood it's just about the
devil
yeah for religious folks skateboarding
kids they're bleeding like that's part
of the allure of it i guess is like oh
this guy bled this guy bleeds that's
what you do in this sport yeah music
you're not there's no blood involved
there's no injuries involved it's a
whole different thing and you got soon
because it was nike and you're taking a
nike sneaker and putting blood on it
yeah they were like what the [ __ ] we
didn't give you this permission that's
how you got sued it's a [ __ ]
corporate thing yeah yeah if and if the
company i'm assuming tony hawk's
skateboard company is like yeah do that
with our yeah absolutely we would love
to do this with you if if there was a
nike collab where they have blood in the
sneaker he's not getting sued because
it's a nike collab nike might catch some
backlash but that's because the devil
[ __ ] again yeah will not actually have a
sneaker with his gay ass nobody cares
yeah i buy it that's great yeah but even
in the midst of this he had such a good
comeback that became like internet lore
that the whole not he tweeted
yeah why did this become such a big o
yeah
i guess like his influence so like
basically the rap i'm pretty sure was
the rap instagram account just rap
posted the link and then he just
comments under it goes not he tweaking
yeah and then just got crazy up votes i
think they pinned it and then everyone's
just like oh we're flooding all the
comments with nothing and now every time
anybody does anything weird it's like
nah he tweaking yeah for the next like
week
yeah but it's like one it just shows his
influence that like he posts some catchy
[ __ ] one he's able to think of like a
funny response yeah and that's like sort
of self-actualizing and ironic and then
the fact that all these kids and like
internet kids are like instagram kids
are picking it up being like yo we're
gonna comment on everything flood the
comments like to me i was like oh that's
actually a pretty cool
way for him to take this moment that's
not about him
and then galvanize it to bring it back
on right yeah yeah smart
so i was actually fairly impressed with
that and i was also that was like a
funny response
yeah now he's interesting he knows how
to market i just think it's a little
unfair to compare the two yeah and i
think he knows it i think like you said
he recognizes like he'll drum it up he
knows what the [ __ ] he's doing yeah
you